[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
die 24 olympischen winterspiele in
peking sind eröffnet china ist zum
zweiten mal olympische ausrichter und
präsentierte sich in einer bunten
eröffnungsfeier als fröhlicher moderner
und friedfertiger gastgeber motto one
world one family
guten abend eine welt eine familie ist
wäre zu schön daran zu glauben doch der
blick nach china und auf diese spiele
ist ambivalent und muss es sein wir
werden tollen sport sehen in den
nächsten zwei wochen und können uns
darauf freuen wie die athleten es tun
aber dass china ein überwachungsstaat
ist der menschenrechte missachtet und
andersdenkende brutal verfolgt ist
realität darüber können und dürfen auch
die schönsten bilder nicht
hinwegtäuschen aus peking stefanie
schöne bahn
weit weg abgesperrt schauen sie in den
schwarzen himmel und warten bei minus
sechs grad die olympischen winterspiele
finden ohne das volk statt und das volk
ist trotzdem stolz
das ist ein großartiges sportfest durch
die olympiade können wir der welt zeigen
dass unser vaterland groß und stark ist
das feuerwerk die olympischen ringe
erstrahlen über peking und es scheint
wie eine eröffnungsfeier von vielen doch
dieser tag der chinesischen winterspiele
war anders politischer und bedrohlicher
als erwartet
denn bevor es überhaupt losging ging ein
diplomatisches feuerwerk der
muskelspiele los denn da kam er wladimir
putin und suchte den schulterschluss mit
schinken der eine hat macht und geld der
andere angst vor sanktionen aus dem
westen da soll china russland helfen die
neue weltmacht achse der kommunisten
fordert den westen heraus
unsere bilateralen beziehungen
entwickeln sich freundschaftlich und als
strategische partnerschaft in nie
dagewesener weise
vor diesem aufgeladenen politischen
hintergrund spielt sich die bildershow
der eröffnungsfeier ab der immer stärker
werdende chinesische nationalismus kommt
heute fast bescheiden daher weil man
sich gross fühlt kann man sich wohl auch
klein inszenieren da wirken die worte
des ioc präsidenten bach beinahe wie
eine farce
halten sie sich an ihr versprechen des
olympischen waffenstillstands geben sie
dem frieden eine chance
und dann gibt es auch diesen moment wo
den athleten die bühne gehört sportler
die sich an das drehbuch der harten chor
ohne regeln halten um in den nächsten
tagen in höchstleistung wetteifern zu
können wie schön wäre es wenn die
olympischen werte die herzen der welt
finden könnten
wir zeigen der welt ja es ist möglich
erbitterte rivalen zu sein und
gleichzeitig friedlich und respektvoll
zusammenzuleben
dazu tanzen kinder mit friedenstauben
ein herz für die spiele und jean ping
winkt scheinbar harmlos der welt zu doch
bei allen lieblichen klängen der
eröffnung bleibt ein dunkler schatten
über den olympischen spielen peking 20
aus frankfurt ist uns nun sylvia schenk
zugeschaltet menschenrechtsanwältin und
mehrere jahre vorsitzende von
transparency international in
deutschland und sportlerin als
leichtathletin sie
1972 an den olympischen spielen in
münchen thailand verschenkt guten abend
rausch aus sowas haben wir gesehen
fröhliche kinder und friedenstauben das
alles in einem überwachungsstaat geht
man zu weit wenn man von propaganda
spielen in peking spricht
eröffnungsfeier sind ja immer etwas
zwischen selbstdarstellung und
propaganda das haben wir in den
vergangenen jahren immer wieder erlebt
ich fand die eröffnungsfeier relativ und
chinesisch ich erinnere mich dass 2008
sehr viel mehr dargestellt wurde
chinesische kultur chinesische
entwicklung die erfindung die china
gemacht hat insofern war es irgendwie
heile welt aber nicht wirklich china aus
meiner sicht heile welt und das hatte ja
dann auch nicht unbedingt was mit der
jedenfalls nicht mit der vollständigen
chinesischen realität zu tun wird gerne
mit ihnen auf die rolle des ioc
vizepräsident bach hat sich von china
verneigt geradezu hat sich bedankt sich
bei den gütigen gastgebern bedankt wie
bewerten sie seine rolle die rolle des
ioc als gast muss er natürlich bestimmte
höflichkeit formen waren also es wäre
jetzt schlecht gewesen wenn er da
irgendwie
kontrovers aufgetreten wäre das problem
nicht ja aber eigentlich in den wochen
zuvor der umgang mit punk schrei dass er
sich dort hat praktisch
instrumentalisieren lassen die
tennisspielerin muss man kurz jagen die
tennisspielerin die zwischenzeitlich
verschwunden war und dass das ioc zu
vielen punkten geschwiegen hat und
einfach die balance nicht gefunden hat
wie man einerseits als gast natürlich
die höflichkeit formen bat aber
andererseits sich nicht
instrumentalisieren lässt und damit sich
praktisch zum komplizen machen lässt
auch für menschenrechtsverletzungen das
ist der vorwurf den sich bach gefallen
lassen muss sich zum komplizen zu machen
und sagt er aber der sport kann jetzt
auch nicht ersetzen was die politik
versäumt und ist es nicht in der tat so
die deutsche regierungs haltung bestimmt
besticht ja auch nicht durch klarheit
wir fahren nicht hinten hin verbinde das
aber mit grundsätzlicher kritik hat bach
da nicht irgendwo auch recht er hat
insoweit recht dass die eu und viele
andere länder deutschland aber auch über
die eu hinaus eine wirkliche strategie
im verhältnis zu china noch nicht
gefunden haben und dann müsste man
dringend daran arbeiten aber es kann
natürlich nicht sein dass der eine seite
auf die andere zeigt die wirtschaft auf
die politik die politik auf den sport
und der sport wieder auf die politik
jeder hat seine eigene rolle zu spielen
und das ioc kann eine friedensbotschaft
schicken und kann auch sehr wohl dafür
sorgen das ist seine eigene
menschenrechtliche verantwortung
wahrnimmt und gleichzeitig ohne die
höflichkeit form zu brechen ohne länder
wirklich ganz auszuschließen sondern
weiter alle zusammen zu bringen trotzdem
zu verhindern dass es sich
instrumentalisieren lässt das muss
diskutiert werden da gibt es mittel und
wege die hat das ioc bisher nicht
gefunden aber sie gehören nicht zu denen
die sagen olympia hätte keinesfalls nach
china vergeben werden dürfen nicht unter
diesen bedingungen als es die vergabe
2015 erfolgte hatte das ioc noch kein
menschenrechts konzept noch keine regeln
im ausrichter vertrag zu
menschenrechtliche verantwortung das hat
sich geändert schon für paris sind die
ausrichter verträge geändert worden es
gibt inzwischen ein fertiges
menschenrechts konzept beim ioc in der
schublade man hat sich noch nicht
getraut das jetzt schon vor china zu
veröffentlichen weil man dann wohl angst
hatte dass man noch mehr als widerspruch
zum dem was auf dem papier steht und wie
man handelt gesehen wird also da wird
sich etwas tun da ist auch schon was
vorbereitet für china kam das zu spät
ein schwieriger spagat herzlichen dank
sylvia schenk
das gespräch haben wir kurz vor der
sendung aufgezeichnet zu den schwierigen
spielen von peking jetzt ein kommentar
von zdf-chefredakteur peter frey
als anführer der unfreien welt so
präsentiert sich china heute bei den
olympischen winterspielen die und putin
ein gipfel der autokraten der westen
schickt sportler und schaut betreten
beck
2008 war mit olympia in peking noch
hoffnung verbunden dass sich das große
china weiter öffnet wenn schon nicht für
die westliche demokratie dann immerhin
für weltweiten handel wandel für
austausch 14 jahre später hat sich china
gewandelt aber nicht zum partner sondern
zum rivalen die aufstrebende supermacht
beansprucht nach außen in asien und
sogar weltweit führung nach innen wird
absolute gefolgschaft verlangt die
demokratiebewegung von hongkong
zerschlagen die uigurische minderheit in
china unterdrückt in kunst literatur
presse kein platz mehr für opposition
die olympischen werte sind ursprünglich
andere friedlicher wettbewerb vielfalt
fair play sportsgeist das kann völker
verbinden aus freude am sport übertragen
wir diese spiele auch in peking werden
sich sportlerinnen und sportler aus
aller welt aneinander messen doch viele
schattenseiten trüben die perfekten
bilder
menschenrechtsverletzungen umweltsünden
zensur
deutschland war heute auf der
ehrentribüne nicht vertreten ohne sich
zu einem diplomatischen boykott zu
bekennen zu viele arbeitsplätze in der
automobil maschinenbau oder
chemieindustrie hängen direkt an
deutschlands wichtigstem handelspartner
scholz und bernburg schweigen vieldeutig
auch die neue regierung übt sich
gegenüber china in realpolitik
niemand will sportlern und zuschauern
den spaß verderben aber wir müssen auf
den gastgeber schauen ein politisch
gleichgeschaltet es nationalistisches
seit corona fast gänzlich abgeschottetes
china das ioc unter dem deutschen thomas
bach bietet einem autoritären regime
eine glanzvolle bühne wer behauptet
diese spiele seien unpolitisch der lügt
ein kommentar von peter frey ob die
waffen während olympia schweigen das ist
der appell im fall des russland ukraine
konflikts braucht es vor allem alle
anstrengungen der diplomatie und damit
beginnen die nachrichten gründe der
pause in die diplomatischen bemühungen
zur lösung der ukraine krise schaltet
sich nun auch bundeskanzler scholz 1 am
februar wird er in kiels gespräche
führen am tag darauf in moskau präsident
putin treffen eine woche zuvor ab
kommenden montag wird frankreichs
präsident marco nach moskau und kiew
reisen für den fall einer russischen
invasion in die ukraine drohte
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
moskau erneut mit drastischen
konsequenzen die auch die ostseepipeline
nord stream 2 betreffen würden inmitten
dieser krise zieht ex kanzler gerhard
schröder weitere kritik auf sich der
russische staatskonzern gazprom hat den
wie putin befreundeten spd-politiker für
den aufsichtsrat nominiert der 77
jährige sitzt bereits dem
gesellschafterausschuss der nordstream
zwei ag vor zuletzt hatte er mit seiner
parteinahme für russland einige kritik
ausgelöst
zugleich muss die nato während der
andauernden schweren spannungen mit
russland
die nachfolge für generalsekretär
stoltenberg regeln der sozialdemokrat
wurde zum künftigen chef der
norwegischen zentralbank ernannt
stoltenberg war seit 2014
generalsekretär der militärallianz sein
mandat läuft ende september aus
bundesweit haben polizisten in trauer
vereint mit bürgern und politikern der
zwei jungen beamten gedacht die vor vier
tagen im dienst erschossen worden waren
um 10 uhr wurde vielerorts mit einer
schweigeminute und glockengeläut den
toten die letzte ehre erwiesen bei einer
nicht öffentlichen trauerfeier in kusel
verurteilte die rheinland pfälzische
ministerpräsident in 3er hämische
kommentare im internet
diese seien menschenverachtend würden
verfolgt und bestraft zu
corona in einem einzelnen fall hat das
verwaltungsgericht osnabrück die
verkürzung des gelesenen status auf drei
monate durch das robert koch institut
für verfassungswidrig erklärt der
beschluss ist aber noch nicht
rechtskräftig und hat keine allgemeine
gültigkeit das rk ii meldet neue
höchststände
248 1838 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden und eine inzidenz von fast
nach hetze und gewalt aufrufen auf der
umstrittenen internetplattform telegramm
hat die bundesregierung erstmals
direkten kontakt zu deren konzernspitze
gehabt innenministerin feser teilte mit
man habe vereinbart den austausch
fortzusetzen und zu intensivieren
bislang hatte sich telegramm
löschanfragen entzogen der messenger
dienst wird unter anderem von radikalen
impfgegnern und querdenkern genutzt
die hetze im netz zu bekämpfen ist
herausforderung genug und nötig dann
besonders besorgniserregend ist längst
auch dass der hass nicht virtuell bleibt
die stimmung bei antigona protesten und
vermeintlichen spaziergängen wird
aggressiver politikerinnen und politiker
werden bedroht ebenso ärzte die impfen
auf unser team aus dem zdf landesstudio
thüringen das diese woche in gera drehte
wurde beschimpft und bedroht nicht zum
ersten mal der bürgermeister von gera
stemmt sich gegen einschüchterung und
radikalisierung aus thüringen daniela
sonntag
videos wie dieses findet geras
oberbürgermeister julian von habe auf
einem twitter kanal gebuhlt direkt vor
seiner wohnung von sogenannten
spaziergängern über 1000 menschen waren
skandierend bei ihm vorbeigelaufen von
abt hat sich bedroht gefühlt und doch
einen der teilnehmer zum öffentlichen
dialog eingeladen es gibt ja doch eine
viel zahl derjenigen die an den
spaziergängen teilnehmen die wirklich
echte sorgen haben dass die aber auch
verstehen wo es eine grenze der
legalität die damit überschritten wird
dass sie eine klarheit haben
[Applaus]
denn die wogen schlagen hoch in gera
mittwoch zogen wieder 3500 menschen
unangemeldet durch die stadt dass wir
als ungeimpfte ausgeschlossen werden das
ist ungerecht und das ist schwachsinn
ist das was ganz anderes dahinter steht
und was hier abgeht das ist auch der
reinste diktatur so schlimm aus der ddr
zeiten viele stoßen sich nicht nur an
den corona regeln sondern auch am start
an sich eine haltung an die
rechtsextreme dann gern andocken
es werden dort vorbehalte gegen die
moderne gesellschaft und gegen die
demokratie geäußert und das ist
natürlich ein umfeld das extrem rechte
akteure dann sehr sehr einfach auch
stärker mobilisieren können und das
stimmt natürlich bei einem großen teil
der
teilnehmenden dazu dass sie sich dadurch
eher noch angesprochen fühlen weil sagte
jemand ja ihr habt recht es denen da
oben doch mal
es ist eine laute minderheit die aber
zunehmend abdriftet schande über sie die
helfer das neue faschistische regime der
leiter der gedenkstätte im ehemaligen kz
buchenwald liest seine post hass mails
täglich seit 2 g in ihrer ausstellung
gibt viele der schreiber aus ganz
deutschland setzen pandemie maßnahmen
und impfungen mit verbrechen an den
juden gleich
und das hat mich sehr erschreckt zumal
tatsächlich ein großer teil dieser
e-mails nicht von dezidiert äußerst
rechten rand sondern aus der mitte der
gesellschaft gekommen sind und das heißt
dass der umstand dass das reflexive
geschichtsbewusstsein eine grundlage
unserer demokratie ist dass diese
gewissheit erodiert
die gedenkstätte und viele andere
akteure haben gemeinsam eine weimarer
erklärung veröffentlicht wenden sich
gegen vergleiche die die ns-verbrechen
verharmlosen wagner hat einige absender
der e mails angezeigt mit anderen
versucht zu reden sowie geras
oberbürgermeister beide aber ziehen eine
grenze
weitergehende formate mit wirklich
rechtsextremen die wird es auch bei mir
nicht geben weil da hört die
gesprächsbereitschaft auf dass er
überhaupt mit lautstark protestierenden
redet dafür bekamen vorne ab auch kritik
aber er will weitermachen als
demokratisches ventil für den unmut
ja impfgegner sie sind eine lautstärke
aber eine minderheit hierzulande die
große mehrheit setzt auf das impfen als
weg aus der korona krise das überhaupt
so schnell impfstoffe entwickelt wurden
war keinesfalls selbstverständlich und
nur möglich weil ein unternehmen wie
biontech zum beispiel eigentlich an
einem impfstoff gegen krebs arbeitete
die neue m rna technologie wurde dann
auf das corona virus angesetzt impfen
gegen krebs das ist die große hoffnung
das ziel quasi personalisierte
impfstoffe zu entwickeln die auf den
einzelnen patienten zugeschnitten sind
noch ist es nicht soweit aber zu
forschungszwecken werden in der
krebsbehandlung schon heute impfstoffe
eingesetzt das zeigt uns am heutigen
weltkrebstag moritz neues
gerade ist der 29 geworden christopher
michels bwl student aus mannheim vor
eineinhalb jahren hat sich sein leben
schlagartig geändert beim essen bricht
er zusammen kommt ins krankenhaus
diagnose hirntumor es folgen bestrahlung
chemotherapie doch nichts davon jetzt
dachte jetzt kann ich nicht mehr weiter
behandelt werden
sondern schon schwieriger macht man sich
natürlich gedanken und führt auch
gespräche
der familie die haben wir dann auch
weitergeholfen dann kann ja zum glück
dass angeboten mit der studie sei ein
tumor sitzt mitten im gehirn wo auch das
sprachzentrum liegt eine op quasi
unmöglich als teilnehmer einer studie
für eine behandlung mit einem impfstoff
bekommt michels regelmäßig eine spritze
seitdem geht es für ihn bergauf alle
drei monate muss er zum mrt die angst
vor einem rückschlag schwingt immer mit
studienleiter michael platten ist
bislang zufrieden denn er erkennt der
hirntumore ist kleiner geworden er ist
nicht weg aber wir sehen doch dass es zu
einem rückgang gekommen ist und das ist
im rahmen der studie tatsächlich ein
sehr schöner erfolg vor allem für einen
michels für die studie in frage kommen
aber nur bestimmte hirntumoren
sogenannte diffuse gliome denn sie
beinhalten häufig eine art fehler im
erbgut ein mutiertes protein das zur
entstehung des tumors führt ein teil
davon wird nach gebaut und unter die
haut der patienten injiziert daraufhin
erkennt unser immunsystem den
fremdkörper und wird aktiviert so können
t helferzellen am tumor andocken und
eine entzündungsreaktion auslösen im
optimalfall schrumpft der tumor dann
langsam krebs impfungen sind nicht
vorbeugen sondern behandeln
grundsätzlich ist dieses prinzip auch
auf andere tumorarten anwendbar eine
erste phase der medizinischen studie ist
bereits erfolgreich abgeschlossen für
erkrankte hätte diese spezifische art
der immuntherapie wesentliche vorteile
gegenüber strahlen und chemotherapien
wenn die impfung wirkt dann durch die
aktivierung des immunsystems nur gegen
die tumorzellen und nicht gegen die
gesunden zellen im körper und in dem
sinne wäre das eine therapie die dann
die gesunden körperzellen beispielsweise
die blutzellen schont und nicht wie eine
chemotherapie angreift und in
mitleidenschaft zieht auch die bochumer
uni klinik nimmt an verschiedenen
studien zur behandlung von krebs teil
dort betrachten sie die impfstudie als
durchbruch die impfstrategie gegen
hirntumoren ist eine neue
vielversprechende strategie die
möglicherweise
zusätzlich zu den bereits etablierten
therapie möglichkeiten wird etwas
vergleichbares gibt es in den usa in
china und auch sonst auf der welt nicht
bis der impfstoff breit eingesetzt
werden kann könnte es noch einige jahre
dauern für christopher michels aber hat
sich schon jetzt viel verändert er ist
dankbar und froh dass durch seine
mitwirkung auch andere profitieren deren
hirntumore eines tages erfolgreich
behandelt werden könnten es ist
natürlich auch gut dass man da der
allgemeinheit auch noch weiterhelfen
kann und mit nur einem selbst
tests an großen patientengruppen stehen
noch aus der 29 jährige aber ist
zuversichtlich seinen hirntumore mit
hilfe der impfungen weiter in schach
halten zu können
und jetzt noch einmal nachrichten
gundela
deutschlands größter stahlproduzent der
traditionskonzern
thyssenkrupp steckt weiter im umbau auf
der hauptversammlung wegen der pandemie
erneut digital abgehalten ging es wieder
um die grüne transformation valerie
haller und die bleibt auch für
thyssenkrupp eine der großen
herausforderungen ja das stimmt dass
thyssenkrupp im kommenden geschäftsjahr
vermutlich schwarze zahlen schreibt das
liegt übrigens auch am grünen
wasserstoff der ist zwar teuer aber auch
eine chance die klima vorgaben die
werden ja immer schärfer und die co2
zertifikate sind teuer doch der umstieg
auf grünen star der bedarf natürlich
investitionen die die branche vermutlich
alleine nicht stemmen kann sie hofft auf
unterstützung vom staat thyssenkrupp
sattelt um baut anlagen für wasserstoff
die mit hilfe von erneuerbaren energien
betrieben werden das ziel grüner stahl
eine investition in die zukunft denn wem
es gelingt mit wasserstoff zu
wettbewerbsfähigen preisen zu
produzieren hat die nase vorn zahlreiche
abnehmer wollen co2 armen stahl um ihre
eigene emissionsbilanz zu drücken und
der energiebedarf der branche ist riesig
ebenso die umweltbelastung fast ein
drittel der deutschen industrie
emissionen kommen von der stahlbranche
thyssenkrupp jedenfalls kämpft sich aus
der krise um einige sparten schlanker
und einen dreistelligen millionenbetrag
für den umbau leichter all das scheint
sich auszuzahlen nur wie es mit der
stahlsparte und ihren 26.000
mitarbeitern weitergeht ist nach wie vor
unklar ein blick noch auf den dax der
gab heute wieder kräftig nach ende einer
achterbahn woche anleger treiben
zinssorgen um die zeiten an der börse
werden ruppiger vielen dank valerie nach
frankfurt wir haben ein ergebnis ganz
knapp aus der fußball bundesliga die
nach kurzer pause wieder startet die
partie hertha bsc gegen vfl bochum geht
in diesen sekunden zu ende es steht
jetzt gerade unentschieden eins zu eins
das vor wangerooge auf grund gelaufene
containerschiff mumbai maersk ist wieder
frei der knapp 400 meter lange frachter
war auf dem weg nach bremerhaven beim
ansteuern der wesermündung aufgelaufen
in der nacht gelang es das havarierte
containerschiff mit neuen schleppern zu
befreien später konnte es dann aus
eigener kraft in seinen zielhafen
bremerhaven einlaufen
am ende dieser woche haben wir uns etwas
schönes verdient und das kommt jetzt die
impressionistische malerei wird von den
meisten heute jedenfalls genauso
empfunden schön als sie entstand war das
anders da war die moderne maltechnik
irritierend und verstörend ein
industrieller aus dem ruhrgebiet aber
verschrieb sich um 1900 dieser neuen
kunst und begann zu sammeln eine
sammlung die der grundstock für das
1922 eröffnete folkwang museum in essen
wurde 100 jahre wird das nun alt und
feiert das jubiläum ab sofort mit seinen
impressionisten kerstin edinger
[Musik]
es sind die schätze der eigenen sammlung
die das museum folkwang in dieser
ausstellung zeigt werke von monet van
gogh oder ghoga
die großen impressionisten geben sich
ein stelldichein
dabei ist auch sie lise mit dem
sonnenschirm von güstrow nur die essener
nennen sie liebevoll ihre mona lisa das
bild ist eines der allerersten werke der
folkwang-sammlung
die impressionisten die wollte neben dem
flüchtigen moment festhalten und
gleichzeitig aber auch sozusagen den
eindruck vermitteln atmosphäre
vermitteln und das kommt in diesem
gemälde wie an kaum einem anderen zur
geltung
ihm ist die sammlung zu verdanken karl
ernst osthaus geboren
1874 der industriellensohn aus hagen
träumt von einer volk falle der kunst
als er ein großes vermögen erbt kaufte
er damals wegweisend und mutig werke
französischer impressionisten karl ernst
osthaus will den aufbruch in die moderne
er ist ein visionär
aus dass heute die kunst zurück ins
leben führen es war anfang des 20
jahrhunderts im ruhrgebiet zwar eine
stark industriell geprägte region und er
wollte ein stück schönheit in die
gesellschaft zu den menschen drin
in der jubiläumsschau treffen die werke
von osthaus auf die sammlung des
japaners koichiro matsuura
obwohl sie zeitgenossen sind sind sich
die beiden nie begegnet sammeln aber zur
gleichen zeit die gleichen künstler karl
ernst osthaus ist der mutigere der
beiden er sucht ständig nach neuen
werken moderner desto besser vincent van
gogh ist eine seiner entdeckung er war
der erste der einwand auch angekauft hat
für eine öffentliche sammlung im jahr
1901 dass das ganz berühmte bild l'amour
sei die ernte bei koga zum beispiel war
auch ganz vorne mit dabei und in hagen
im folkwangmuseum waren auch die ersten
ausstellungen dieser künstler dabei also
pionieren
nach dem tod von osthaus zieht seine
sammlung 1922 von hagen nach essen das
ist die geburtsstunde des museum
folkwang
es ist das erste museum in dem
gegenwartskunst eine wichtige bedeutung
hat so angepasst die impressionistischen
werke heute erscheinen mögen damals
waren sie der inbegriff von modernität
die ausstellung erzählt vom festen
glauben zweier sammler an ihre kunst die
geschichte hat ihnen recht gegeben
toll ab sonntag für alle geöffnet so
viel von uns
und um 0.30 meldet sich hier christopher
wehrmann mit unserem heute so x update
[Musik]
guten abend gleich schauen wir
meteorologisch nach china aber erst auf
unser wetter aber da sagt überquert eine
kaltfront es fällt regen und schnee und
es gibt gewitter an der nordsee es kann
auch glatt seien auf den straßen bei
meist +3 bis -2 grad es weht ein starker
bis stürmischer südwest- bis westwind
und morgen vormittag gibt es noch letzte
schauer im nordosten dann wird das ein
freundlicher samstag am nachmittag
kommen dichtere wolken mit regen von
nordwesten heran und die breiten sich
dann am sonntag weiter richtung südosten
aus und es wird wieder stürmisch und
jetzt nach peking denn im hinterland
finden die ski wettbewerbe statt genauer
in den beiden orten janzing und tanja
kuh
schauen wir auf die wettkampfstätte john
lee kalt ist es da im winter schnee
fällt äußerst selten das liegt an der
großen landmasse der nähe zur wüste gobi
im sommer ist es dort feucht war mehr
als die hälfte des jahres regens kommt
im juli und august rutter der winter ist
dagegen extrem trocken da schneit es
kaum und es bläst ein eisiger
nordwestwind statt schnee bringt der
maximal sand aus der wüste gobi ohne
schneekanonen wären winterspiele dort
undenkbar seit november sind sie im
dauereinsatz
nun liegt zu 100 prozent kunstschnee auf
allen pisten und zufahrtswegen mit den
dafür benötigten wasser und energie
mengen während 30.000 menschen dort ein
halbes jahr lang gut versorgt schönen
abend